i mean if your race is up to you that's
up to you yeah
always tell me that i said your
discretion i grew up in the south bro i
don't mind racist
they put it all on the table what do you
tell me he goes
man i don't use the n-word unless you do
[Laughter]
that boy is a fool he's so crazy
his stories too man how he used to live
uh
not maybe not in the backyard but that
can join like the fence separate them to
david duke the leader of the kkk
he said i don't even know mal's working
out with this guy he kept throwing this
racist [ __ ] all the time
bro he's the guy he's the guy
wait he created it or was just a leader
well you know it's old as [ __ ] but he
was like what he's like
the leader now the leader like he's
still killing it
yeah he was like he was like featuring
for them i don't know i didn't mean
killing it but like
you know he is killing it but he uh he
was like the feature for the kkk now
he's the
the main guy they go they go by weird
things like grand wizards cyclops and
yeah all that stuff you know like like
some dungeons that's how you know that
shit's old
yeah wizard wizard what
so i i mix colognes because like i'm an
abstract person
so the first layer is chanel blue oh
damn and the
second layer is time for ombre leather
i've never
heard of anyone doing that yeah mixing
the two it smells [ __ ] like like you
you
like if you it's like you mix some
spices yeah like if you smell delicious
that's what brenda's trying to
if you know since you know how to like
you can mix like a sweet scent with a
spicy scent yeah yeah
yeah you get that too much sweet it's
just over overwhelming
then you smell like armenians smell gay
yeah
and i live in west hollywood yeah
they smell real good though you know
they smell good they look good
right they drive the best there's a guy
in my building with the uh
the new uh what is it the maybach suv oh
those are real
yeah that mercedes one yeah yeah like
why are you living in this apartment
yeah your car is like well yeah flexing
probably bad at business if you live in
that one-bedroom
studio gays are good at business you
know how much dick he's getting in that
box any idea how much dick that man is
getting that thing
that thing is sick wait so you're on
what's hollywood yeah i'm right across
the street from the comedy store
oh really yeah i didn't know that i
wasn't i was used to being in the
village
it was expensive though i mean caught a
good covert deal
david you smart ah man come on a little
bit a little bit
because you split time between la and
austin
um i wouldn't necessarily say i split
time like i befriended a doctor
in austin who made it easier for me to
be there like i would much rather prefer
you know like be in la because like i
got two kids
here but i befriended the doctor he was
like hey you can give me whatever for
this room he got a high rise
oh damn in downtown he's just he just
[ __ ] with you yeah bro like he just
became a real big fan he was like bro
since i started
you know coming to your comedy shows
more clients coming because i shot him
out like in my shows oh really
yeah yeah what kind of doctors he's a
chiropractor oh wow there you go
you you so we're loosed on the term
doctor around
right you said a doctor yeah
yeah i got a lot of strippers coming to
him now
oh really i'd be like he can help your
arch like you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah i sent this one stripper to him
that had an accident and she gonna get
back like 60k
dang she fell off the pole or something
nah somebody uh rear-ended her
oh and they weren't having sex it was in
the car oh got it okay
i was like damn that bad yeah yeah she
got hit she was dumb because she was
just complaining about her back i'm like
what happened she was like somebody hit
me the other day i'm like girl you need
to
they're called frankie yeah right yeah
they're called the bulldogs
yeah that's about the general well out
in california it's the general but i
think that's insurance right
general oh i thought it was like in
colorado it's
frank azar or the bulldog two different
dudes and my grandma rest in peace
when we went an eight i was a kid we
were at tony romo's the rib place oh
yeah and they were doing construction on
the carpet and the carpet just kind of
slid up just a little and she was old as
[ __ ]
and she was like yeah you go to the
bathroom she always stole the uh knives
from tony roma
she should put them in her purse like
that yeah she loved him
yeah so she was walking the bathroom
fell on the carpet broke her hip
and i was a kid i didn't think of it dog
she called up that frank azar the
bulldog
dude they got her biggest brother yeah
is is he still is he still around i
think he passed away
oh damn shout out to he got my grandma
money that's a plug out here like i know
people
like that do that for a living brother
like go to a job
and work it for like six months and then
have an accident they'll slip and fall
no because you they gonna pay you um
what is it the
when you're off from work unemployment
yeah whatever that is the disability the
disability yeah
so you get that for like a year and then
in a year your case settle you get a
check for like 40 50 grand
i want to hustle here there's no reason
for anybody to be broken yeah we can't
slip and fall in comedy well but that's
what
you can yeah you can what'd you call it
got a million uh
george wallace for what from the uh from
the
place he had a residence oh the in uh in
vegas
like he tripped and fell on the stage
you can have uh wrists like uh
cert like insurance we're like let's say
i got a car accident i can't talk
anymore
then they have to cover like since i
can't work i can't speak anymore
they pay you out nice it's kind of
expensive
oh it's expensive for that insurance uh
it's not bad
but i don't know if you need it i mean
hopefully
so you chilling out here right now like
you out here for a bit
yeah i'm out here for a minute uh let me
see next week i
gotta do uh like a week long in vegas i
don't really what's up going to the lab
factory no i'm at the uh
la comedy club at a strategy oh okay
yeah yeah i don't really i'm not a big
fan of vegas
me neither i'm just not i'm just not a
vegas dude i'm not a vegas guy man like
there's places everyone was moving to
and i started looking at property in
vegas i'm like i don't know if i can do
it i mean i'll say i'm like live on the
[ __ ] trip like a psycho
kids but just when you look outside of
that it's so
[ __ ] hot man it's so hot and then to
do a week long if it shows like
damn do you have to stay in the
stratosphere are you being disciplined
yeah you have to stay there
is this like work release punishment
yeah what'd you do man they forced you
to stay in the strasbourg
that place is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show man i
sleeping with no girls at the
stratosphere
no they got that hot pocket yeah look at
that
my necklace what's called frankie's all
right
you can stop by that one spot what's
that spot the the bunny room or whatever
bunny ranch bunny right now that's about
an hour but uh
i don't want tomorrow to pass all that
say less that's where lamar loom did his
thing yeah
he was there for a week though and then
they have like a bungalow or like a
vip room he was in there just doing all
the drugs and had just
unlimited girls coming in that's that
dan bilzerians though
yes dad did the same thing like he was
like at the bunny ranch no but
he was just his life in general yeah
skiing and like snowboarding and like
staying up for like four days and
banging chicks
that's drugs cocaine yeah but he made
all this
yeah he got [ __ ] up but he didn't he's
in a little bit of trouble i guess
and this is all rumors on the internet
but there's all these videos dedicated
to it because
he invested like a ton of his money in
this cbd like uh vape thing
and then went belly up and i guess like
now notice you don't see him
posting with hoes and stuff like that or
that cancel culture came out he's like
oh [ __ ] i'm good
i don't think it's the money he's
probably chilling he's probably just
quiet i read about him
because the first time i ever heard
about dan bizzarian i was in vegas
and i was chilling with this chick and
then she got a call
and she was like i got to go i said
where are you going i got to go meet
daddy
who the [ __ ] is that eddie
because you know yeah so i figured he
must have been a millionaire then later
she told me what dan was there i was
like oh okay
yeah kind of got to take the l on that
one see his last post that's from
christmas doug yeah he didn't post it in
a minute
that was oh [ __ ] isn't the food like a
serial gambler
like yeah well the thing is i guess the
story on him is he grew up super rich
like his dad was a
jagillionaire and then gave him money
and then he went around like all the
gambling tables was like oh no i made my
money gambling
but that's like someone being like oh
i'm a headliner and they show up at the
store and like do we haven't
nobody knows what tours you've been
doing so that's what happened to him and
he was like you didn't make your money
doing this
i guess yeah then he said he was a navy
seal
then you got you got real navy seals
being like ah we don't remember being
buds and he was like yeah because i
broke both my legs but i still made it
through it no
then real name steel's like i don't
think so doug
so it's just it's time yeah it's time i
think because he went on rogan obviously
people's you know a lot of people hate
him a lot of people love him 36 million
followers
so it's like a lot of people [ __ ] with
him because we live in this crazy
lifestyle
and but you don't know like his
personality on rogan i thought he like
you did him justice like if he did like
a weekly podcast i think he would help
him out
yeah like logan paul like you see him on
youtube like when he was really young
like this
ass clown yeah yeah yeah and then when
you hear him like oh damn he's actually
a decent person yeah sometimes you just
gotta hear a [ __ ] talk
true and then obviously dan's just
flexing all the time it's firing guns
and [ __ ]
those girls like sucking on machine guns
and [ __ ]
like deep throating grenades and [ __ ]
yeah yeah
come on girl suck this grenade
he's like hell no money making me crazy
hell yeah man it kind of be scaring me
sometimes
really like you do pretty good though
yeah i do decent like but as i climb you
know it's like
man like my requests get weirder and
weirder
hell yeah i was telling rogan
i was talking this morning i was telling
him i was like yeah dave lucas and spell
and i are going to go on the road and
he's like now that's a [ __ ]
show man he's like david a monster i'm
like yeah
big time everyone [ __ ] with you yeah
try to man i mean you know got a solid
rep
i mean if people don't mess with me it's
like that's on them yeah it's like
that's how i am like i'm such a nice guy
if you don't [ __ ] with me that's that's
some insecurity you have man but you
know what i realized bro
like reading comments uh like before any
comments
you're right i don't used to but i get a
my producer keeps me in the loop
about a lot of stuff yeah that makes
sense so he was like uh telling me about
something somebody said
so and then the thing that i motivate
i've noticed is that it seems like
the internet can smell a little bit of
alpha male energy on somebody
and start hating them that's what i feel
well yeah because it's a bunch of betas
right
a lot of it like a lot of bait is there
hey yeah so
like you're out here doing the damn
thing like man why the [ __ ] is he doing
damn things like well
he's very talented works very hard and
you did it remember you gave up
now did you used to go hard in the
comments because you you can go harder
i've seen you go hard on some people
let's take a little pause here from
chatting with my boy david lucas
and laces out chappelle lacy because man
far far too long wall street has
neglected
the average investor we're talking about
you giving out the same old generic
advice like buy
etfs meanwhile for the ultra wealthy
they get access to premium investment
strategies and resources
that divide didn't sit well with titan
that's right we talk about titan
so they built an active investment
management platform that's available
for everybody thanks to titan out
everyday consumers can have their
capital invested
like a world-class hedge fund to get
started download the titan app
their titan delivers daily updates
in-depth videos deep dive reports
podcasts everything you need
titan insurers that clients know what
they want and
why they're behind their investments all
right unlike conventional investing apps
titan doesn't invest their clients into
publicly traded etfs
or mutual funds instead titan has the
in-house investment team that actively
manages invest strategies designed to
outperform the market
we got you man to start investing with
titan today and get three months free
visit titanvest.com fighter
that's three months of investing for
free make
bank bro titanfest.com fighter titan
first class for your capital it's 2021
man and mental health is
everywhere finally people are talking
about it you've been talking your
friends around the water cooler on work
break
you've been talking your friends at the
gym they're not professionals man get
with a real licensed professional i'm
talking about with better help it's a
customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions
with a real therapist so you don't have
to see anyone on camera if you don't
want to
but we got you covered it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy and
you can start communicating within your
therapist
in under 48 hours all right joins
millions
joins i don't like men's anymore joins
the millions of people who are seeing
what therapy is really about see if it's
for you because you are your greatest
asset and this podcast with david lucas
is sponsored by betterhelp
and the finally listeners get temps off
their first month at betterhelp.com
fighter that's better help b-e-t-t-e-r
help h-e-l-p dot com slash fighter
did you used to go hard in the comments
because you you can go harder i've seen
you go hard on some people
when i first got on killed tony and uh i
started getting like these weird
keyboard warrior fans
you know what i'm saying trying to fire
back at you yeah bro i would literally
like go today messages and video chat
them i video chatted several
oh really no i'll be like brother
like they give me ain't like they'll say
something crazy i'm like bro what i'm
working tonight at the comedy store
pull up you're talking on that level
yeah
bro guys like you talking real time so
for those of you that don't know
christian chin cat like david's like the
main
roaster on kill tony like when people
get lit up it's him
it's yeah it's it's him people [ __ ] up
him business
try and fight you this being told me
he's going to take me to back and [ __ ]
me
david just kept going and he was getting
all crazy he was like
shut up you don't have a fighter you
don't have to chop so that's what you
know it's like man
[ __ ] you that's what you know you got
him oh yeah
i saw what you did to that uh girl the
other day
you posted it yesterday in austin
yeah bro i was at the uh the sunset room
and i said
one of my jokes and she was like you're
misogynistic you hate women
and then she stood up and she's like i
have a baby and i was like [ __ ] i don't
give a [ __ ]
what was she thinking i don't know he
was he was he was like he was like
she wouldn't stop and then her friend
her friend was like hey you're trying to
tell her to stop your friend's like
please don't do it
do you know what you're dealing with
like you're poking that dragon
it's like man like that's what's funny
about people don't realize like we're
the first
we do this you know what i mean yeah and
what you said in the first time we've
heard it
so i have some [ __ ] in the chamber
that's yeah you're not ready
yeah you think someone hasn't said
misogynistic to you
while you're on stage like like you
haven't heard it before like any woman
that deals with me knows how i am and
they're like i take it with a grain of
salt because he's a comedian like
yeah you're just telling jokes cause you
better because that's that's the thing
let me see it
right am i bad no you're good you're
good don't touch me like that though
you working out now man
now
you got at 9am
[Music]
where did you work at
she's like don't say another one
her friend's trying to that was when her
friend's like please please
before he heads my way
he looked like an advisor
all right
[Laughter]
that's what people don't realize about
you like you come with this ammo all
right
you've always had that though it started
or did it school bro
oh it started really waiting for school
really because i was a chubby kid
and like i would get really oh bro nah
and so like uh
you know my parents weren't doing well
at first so we lived in the hood but i
went to a private school
where's this at in georgia all right you
know what i'm saying so like um
i would get it i would be straight at
school but i would get it
when i came home for cause you were
going to private school
no i would just get it because i'm a
chubby kid oh like oh cause you were in
the hood
yeah yeah the private school no one
really no nobody messed with him but
when you but when you got
home and like going around the hood yeah
so i just got tired of trying to fight
people and i saw that
their words actually work better than
like beating somebody for sure
so i just started like roasting roasted
just lighting them up
but also it's like uh like you do that
what's the rose show you do roast me i
[ __ ] like
roast meals i [ __ ] love but it's also
like they're
like those especially those kids like
i'll see the fat comments and the joke
like you've heard it
oh man yeah so it's like if someone does
something like or even on that rose show
it's like if there's any fat jokes like
target
none of this is original it's all been
said before man that's why people call
me like a good
counter puncher like on that show
because like yeah those fat jokes don't
affect me
no yeah yeah
you know there's other someone made a
whole compilation of your like all your
roasts
oh man that's from from that from
grocery dude he
man i've watched that i've watched it
like me too i love it who's the old head
on there
oh boo capone he's a god he's funny
funniest guy in the world bro
you said he's unreal which one he's on
roastable because it's like which one's
he
buca the oldest dude he he used to be
bad he's always been funny
but he used to be too loaded on the show
you know what i'm saying then when he
started like not getting loaded
yeah like he like gloated like drunk
yeah yeah yeah oh he'd be drunk yeah oh
dude he got like
they they light up new guys he doesn't
stop
and then there one guy tries to match
his energy and won't let him talk
and then he just waits waiting so you
let me talk now you guys yeah man
and then just boo capone k-a-p-o-n-e
book opponent no no no no boom like
b-o-o
oh cupcake yep
there you go he looks funny oh that dude
he's so
[ __ ] up and the story about boo capone
but like in the early 90s he was signed
to like mac 10.
oh really he was wrapping his ass off
really yeah he could wrap his ass off
man he's
and he just became a roaster yeah yeah
he's mad like
so monday nights at the improv you know
it's black now yeah yeah so bro a little
better
more better monday yeah i would do kill
tony and my spot at the store and then
go to mo better bro we roast for
literally like three four hours
oh they roast each other around outside
like outside like we were some people
coming out the door like huh for real so
[ __ ] funny man yeah man bucapone is
hilarious he's he's my favorite like
in the world by far and then they had
some new guy and then he started
roasting the hose and i was like this
ain't get in
right and then boo was like nah man
because you can't really rest
right so then he started going in on him
really so funny man
craig smith is another one craig smith
he comes from uh
craig smith is like in terms of like
fighting like he's one of them guys
he's not going to throw a lot of punches
but the punches he throws oh my god
they're like but are any of them uh
beside you like straight up comics
or they're just yeah um craig does
comedy
yeah brent does comedy cpc he's funny uh
and i think that kev on stage does
comedy yeah but as far as like
touring and doing them yeah they're all
doing touring no i'm saying like as far
as tournament i'm probably the one that
wants the most yeah got it because
like i don't know what else uh boo raps
and craig got like a lot of stuff he's
doing on youtube and stuff
bro you work your ass off i tried you're
hustling you are hustling like you went
out you went out to austin just started
running running your own show did you go
out there because uh kill tony was
like you were following that those guys
so um tony
you know tony i came for my birthday uh
we're supposed to do some shows but he
ended up getting covered
so i still had the flight in the hotel
book uh so i went out there and you know
he's like hey man you know come out here
you know move out here
and i'm like 20 by the end of the day i
got two kids in there you always trying
to get everybody to move out
right yeah let me chill right like i got
two kids of them yeah
i'll try to come out here twice a month
but yeah if i don't see the money
i can't just like i'm doing good in l.a
so i
i can't just like move everything i
worked for and
you know because we had a bad years like
in a relationship you know
so it's like i'm not just going to move
all my eggs to
austin like i'll come as needed yeah but
i'm not going to move out there
you love you love la i love la man i've
been here since i was 19 and i'm 30 now
bro
and i know austin should i didn't know
that people love austin i love austin
too
and obviously we have more homeless here
in la but austin homeless different
they're
they parked their bikes outside the tent
they got like real [ __ ]
there you have an area there by the
vulcan brothers it looks like harlem
like
in the city you know how like if you see
a movie it's like don't go down that
alley
in your life you've never seen that
alley bro oh this is that out
behind the vulcan you look back oh my
god right next to a homeless
shelter yeah it's like the roughest [ __ ]
you've ever seen
for real and it's just packed with
people man outside
i saw some little white girl on a
[ __ ] bird just go down the alley
[Laughter]
over on her she gets raised
they're too lit for me on uh sixth
street bro i'll be telling people i'm
like we partied at la but austin party's
on a different level
different level they get they get white
girl ways it's like new orleans down
there man yeah
that's exactly how it is it's like just
out of there oh man and wild
new orleans is like that sixth street or
whatever oh yeah every night
uh you know i've never bourbon have you
performed in new orleans
they don't really have a comedy they
just have that house of blues and
there's a theater there i supposed to do
it right before coveted
but i've done house of blues in new
orleans before new orleans is a weird
comic down because they haven't really
i was like i was going to say they
seemed like they'd be like like mark
orman's out of there
[ __ ] video like they have some legit
comics but as far as like this
there's no like scene there yeah yeah i
think they'll have a comedy club yeah
because there's some
beasts that could that come out of there
but there's nothing really popping oh
[ __ ] yeah
i didn't know that yeah wow but yeah i
got i don't know
like every time we walk out every night
on sick try hearing for you
remember i had to leave the bar i left
with you yeah you're in this barn and i
knew shabbat was like this can't be
like i feel drinking i i'm seven years
seven years away from alcohol i had to
drink to be around that many people bro
oh you do i don't drink before i go on
stage when i get off stage
and i know i gotta interact with people
i gotta get in there yeah see where the
opposite i drink before i go on stage
because it makes me feel way looser and
i don't drink off stage
at all i like you don't
i like that tight feeling though i like
that yeah there's pros and cons for sure
like i was
uh on another podcast they were asking
me like what i do for energy before i go
on stage
i hold my pee oh really to give me a
sense of oh damn
yeah because i'm such like low energy so
i hold my pee
so it's like i move out i make myself
move more because like you know when you
got to pee you're moving
yeah like that sense of urgency what's
dope about your low energy is you hit
so powerful yes it's like
monsters right it's insane like i mean
i've seen you quite a few times like i
mean
just back and forth at the store you
know but like you know watching you
get down this weekend because i hadn't
seen you in a bit and watching you get
down with us
at vulcan i was just like damn yeah when
i tell you backstage i was like the
first time
him and i've been nervous in a long last
time
[Laughter]
no but it's but i like that feeling yeah
i like it like i like those
like it's like when we were talking
about what uh would crack them up
thursdays when we do the development
spots and how she pretty much
yeah on the show pretty much put you up
with the lights
but i'm saying like when we did the
shows at the vulcan you would go on
there and kill it remind me of the like
not obviously not now because the code
would remind me of the store before
everything
happened right right like oh yeah so
nervous guys like [ __ ]
you look at the line i'm like oh my god
are you following [ __ ] joey diaz
right yeah nightmare you know let's just
kill her kill her kill it but
it brings you to like a whole another
level it felt good though i was like
damn there's that nervousness
yeah it's like i feel like you need that
man like oh 100
i like to be challenged like you know
because it's like i don't know how your
audience is going to respond to me it's
your audience yeah
my audience yeah a lot of dudes so a lot
of dudes
yeah yeah they loved it though and then
the the owner of vulcan when i came in
the back
you know you're on stage i'm like dog
how are you not booking this dude
every [ __ ] week he's like we are man
when
assad
i've seen this dude go hard on stage
with comics so
he uh you got shows pretty good yeah
yeah you guys oh yeah
you got rappers though
tony's my boy so i'm in l.a and i've
been on the show numerous times so i
know how the vibe is but
you know schultz came to l.a doesn't
didn't know of it at the time he just
came here
he said david little know he's like what
he does i got some in the chamber but i
wasn't ready
because he yeah shows came with a couple
he came with a couple yeah
but literally you had everything
everybody called rapper did you call him
you said he looked like the screen mask
or something
like scream i legit didn't like him bro
his energy is [ __ ] up
oh you know he wasn't but i mean because
you know normally like
i have my exchange with people and like
yeah i'm out in the back yeah everyone
on the stage
uh in the back okay oh god you know i
dab people i mean i appreciate you for
being a good sport
you know you know appreciate you for
being cool about this man
i usually do that too whenever i do
something to someone in the crowd and
they didn't really ask for it i usually
say thank you
it depends yeah they're being assessed
they're getting asses
did he know the vibe yeah and this is
usually he like he's uh
you know like he is yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's pretty easy like his energy
like afterwards and then like i saw him
a couple of more times
you know working the door and it's just
like damn bro normally you know
after i have an interaction with
somebody i get a little respect you know
what i'm saying like he did me up and
didn't even know me when i was working
the back door
you know so because it's like i roasted
eric griffin then he asked me to go on
the road with him you know like i
roasted shoulder he's like hey when
you're gonna be here here and there
and it's like so it's like there was no
uh
nothing not saying i was looking for
something yeah i love it but no but you
usually
respect it between comics especially
after if you light somebody up
you know it is what it is like i don't
dislike maybe rap took it personal or
something yeah
that's my boy he's like dave you go
you go in though i work in the door
though that i
that's the people i talk to most if you
want to find out about comics ask
the door the door guys they know
everyone because i'll be like oh that
guy's cool like he's not
cool man you know he's never tipped us
i'm like what the [ __ ]
and there's people that you would never
know like well you know how much he
makes
right like i know people you would never
think i'm like god damn
bro me and um uh anthony jesselnick
we didn't really have it was awkward
though um
i started working the back door i didn't
know a lot of white comics you know
coming into the comedy store i knew
anthony justin nick was
but i didn't know the full bearded
anthony johnson nick so he comes and i
was like oh yeah i need to see your id
bro i was like where you going who's he
like
do you know where you're going because
he didn't say he's like i was like do
you know where you're going he's like i
always know where i'm going
and then i was like and then he pointed
to the sign i was like
okay yeah he's a beast
and then uh theo vaughn's uh assistant
at the time what's your name
tara i can't remember what i mean yeah
she got fired theo vaughn's assistant
was like do you know who that is
you need to go apologize right now i'm
like i'm not apologizing for my job
i just didn't know who he was with a
beer though and it happened with uh uh
andrew santino
you know he was santino no not until i
started working at the comments we're
like hey man where you going
exactly you're just doing your job
though
but also for them it's like you also
realize the new door guy be cool man
yeah
right wait so did you start coming out
here or started back i started
i started comedy the first time i ever
got on stage was in high school because
i did
oh [ __ ] i did mtv on mama in high school
you you was on your mama yeah yeah yeah
yeah
really yeah i was like i was a celebrity
in high school
dude i love that show
there was another there's another comic
uh george lucas george lopez
i didn't know not george i know you
talking about the mexican dude yeah yeah
yeah yeah he uh he was uh he was on it
he was on it
the host of roast me was on it brandon
lewis he was or damn i didn't know that
he was on it yeah for real to hear
what's happening mtv's kind of popped
off a lot george perez
george yeah he's a beast i love jordan
super you ever have to follow george
no be speaking he's lights their [ __ ]
room up
i know monster love that he had baby
joey diaz
yeah yeah he's a mexican joey diaz like
yeah thinner yeah but that's
that's his style yeah raunchy like yeah
but it's great
monster it works monster um yeah that
yeah
mtv's had like they've had so much
talent come through there and obviously
they just double down on [ __ ]
16 and pregnant but they've like they
had that guy code
think about that that was [ __ ]
schultzy
charlemagne ocd chrissy d was on there
uh jessica uh what's her name annie
letterman was on there annie letterman
was on there
carly aquilino comics tonic
uh what's his name he's [ __ ] little
duval little duval duval
involved i think about all that and then
him and charlemagne had his show for a
second too
i think it was called like ain't that
america or something like that but that
was obviously short-lived but like yeah
a lot of people
come from that yeah big time and little
duvall has been
around for a minute he's he's mastered
instagram
he's mastered it i watched le duval when
i was a kid in comic view
how how old is little duval at minimum
45.
you know you know he has his own he has
to be you know he has his own plane what
yeah he always he lives he lives on some
island
in the uh he flies he flies he's 43.
duval's made that much buddy
that's what i said and i apparently he
has and he said he bought like
it's not like a big ass you know like
drake [ __ ] off-white plane
but it's like he has a probably smaller
private jet yeah he lives on i forget
where he lives he lives on like a
straight-up island mm-hmm
living like charlemagne to talk about
all the time and uh showing me like you
see little duvall he's like nah i
couldn't get out there man
because he's flying he lives on an
island damn he said [ __ ] yeah people
don't understand how good that show
money is when you're a comedian
tv no no no like oh you got my touring
like touring
if you yeah yeah no no on the low end
you can come back on a good weekend with
20.
oh yeah a low that's low yeah that'd be
a bad weekend right
right especially as a headline it'd be a
bad weekend yeah he yeah he's he sells
out pretty strong too yeah he does and
he matches instagram bro
oh dude and then he got so he got and
he's in a good position because
that's i hate instagram but i just said
cause i have to
but he he he posted memes in the video
so he got like the 21 and up
crowd and the older cats that know him
from comic view yeah oh yeah and also
the comics that don't fit like the older
comics that don't figure out social
media they just it's like you get left
behind unless you're a real old head
yeah yeah you have that like old like
ron white doesn't be on instagram doing
photos
yeah some people yeah you know somewhat
younger and like you gotta like you
gotta figure out instagram yeah you
really have to like it's your it's your
own pr it's just like what you said i
hate instagram i hate
all [ __ ] social media to begin with
you gotta like but you gotta do it
sometimes i'm like damn i posted in two
days let me find it yeah they get
stressed like
you start searching through your phone
and [ __ ] well today i was like man
they added more tickets and shows in
kentucky i need to do something right
my guy was like man do some in the gym i
was like [ __ ] i have to
that was his [ __ ] video me on the
leg machine or some [ __ ]
i don't want to do this man you've got
to you have to
it's like counting you know accounts 54
for the longest he's like no we don't
need to do that
we don't need to do that podcast we want
to do that i'm like i'm telling you this
is this is the thing yeah
not everyone their [ __ ] aunt has a
podcast oh for real you you have
as a comic that's what you like this is
this is how i sell tickets right like
this
this is it man you oh you have your own
podcast yeah i had one with uh william
montgomery
uh oh yeah the brothers brothers and
curses brothers encouraged them
his full name is william you calling
bill or something really no
william you ever seen william montgomery
let me see him the most
interesting person well just by his name
is he run for he's like yeah he's like a
government job
he's kind of no politician he's kind of
like andy coffin
oh really oh dude he's great and he says
the wildest [ __ ]
his his kill tony appearances are
another one that's like that's my dog
really dope on the right yeah on the
right oh no i know him yeah he's great i
would i
uh i forget where i saw him he was
hammered though yeah oh yeah
oh no is that him in front of my car
that's my [ __ ] car right there that's
your car that's my car
yeah that's uh so me and him shot
a uh a video inside of
uh we did a video for a realtor
inside that was in i think huntington
beach or redundant is one of those
beaches far out
and the guy is like the something
over the head of ferrari racing oh damn
oh [ __ ] like
yeah that's a real car there dog yeah
he's such an interesting character
he was so hammered though yeah we had to
improv together it's
hammered we were doing some show and
then i got off stage and he was talking
about
he's giving me some tips i think i'm
podcasting yes
sounds right no he
[Laughter]
yeah that's my car man oh [ __ ] the
inside garage bro wait send that to
china
you guys are shooting a commercial for
him yeah we shot a real estate
commercial
so like so the realtor who
uh sells like all those multi-million
dollar houses
he does like like a mini movie
like a sketch that's the instagram
sketch to sell the house that's cool
he hit me and will up and you guys wrote
it for him
no he uh he pretty much had he had it
ready to go just wanted you guys we
tagged it along the way like oh you
think you can switch that out do this to
make it a little
that's cool let me see the video chin
yeah and this is his garage
yeah bro insane
and those are just the cars that are
underground that car there's oh
he's got a bunch more that 918 is
ridiculous
oh i like that ben
is that a bentley yeah am i correct yeah
gt i think i'm learning uh he had a
ferrari simulator
what is that like you take a video game
with us
jps screen like pole position yeah like
actual drivers because they've gotten so
good they'll have like the real [ __ ] and
they do that to get better at driving
oh got it that's jason yeah jason f1
yeah he has that at home
yeah he likes stick shifts and [ __ ]
alert i know right
alert i'm like what better focus on
[ __ ] i'm gonna send him this one too
what
he has a lakers indoor basketball court
at his group
damn right you got another one buddy and
he's just crushing it
bro this dude is balling you ever hear
from him anymore now probably not
the guy no no no was he was he like a
fan of you guys or something
so the guy who owns the house knew
nothing of us
you know how have you got to sell the
house do it you know what i'm saying and
then was this the house he was selling
with the lakers court yeah
you better be the biggest [ __ ] lakers
fan bro
damn damn indoor too in this full court
not half just half
all right all right it's still cool
though yeah
not as cool but still cool well that's
what rick glassman said we were we're in
the back in the green room and we're
bragging he was talking about something
i said doc once you come to my house man
i got a full core [ __ ] like we're you
know we're just talking [ __ ]
he goes yeah it's definitely outdoors
though because you're not making the
money to have an indoor court
[Laughter]
i don't do well outside here but i will
still come over and play
your glasses so [ __ ] funny hilarious
he was like come work out with this man
when you're in la come join the group
yeah
well i i'm told to start coming to zoo
culture um you know what i'm saying come
work out with y'all boys choose
something to do something you know what
i'm saying you got kids so you're up
early anyways
uh they don't live on me i got baby
mamas oh oh yeah
you go you got two you said baby mama
two babies hold up two different kids
two different baby mamas
oh damn
you got a six-year-old and one-year-old
right yep damn david
yeah got a six-year-old and you're a
good dad i'm a great dad hell yeah
yeah you seem like both girls both girls
damn
i feel like it's scary having girl more
scared of having girls
than boys the good thing about girls is
i don't gotta never worry about getting
married because they'll take care of me
when i get old that's true
so that's boys would put your ass in a
nursing home
with that [ __ ] as soon as my dad starts
tweaking i'm like
but i want six kids though yeah me too
you want a lot of kids i want more kids
but you don't you gotta like
kind of settle on a girl you'll find you
find a ride or die
you you just go you would you be down
for six kids six different baby
mamas uh four i stopped at four baby
mamas
you stopped at four baby mama isn't it a
nightmare though like dude like me
michael were talking about like we were
watching 60 and pregnant and they're
like dropping the kids off and [ __ ]
she's like can you imagine if we were
separated dealing with kids i'm like
that'd be a [ __ ]
it's tough enough when i started making
decent money when my problems went away
oh really because they yeah they're like
child support you know what i'm saying
like
oh got it you pay your child support you
can do whatever you want you can take
your kid for a month
yeah yeah and oh so you cool with your
baby mamas mm-hmm they get paid so they
yeah what does that complain about and
the ethnicity of the baby mamas
the first one now that's probably coming
next
baby mama there you go uh the other
one's black so uh
my first baby they're both black but
she's native american and black
okay my youngest uh her mom was jamaican
oh
have you always been a ladies man uh
probably since like 15. when i got
popular in school playing football
that makes sense oh yeah you were like a
real football player mm-hmm
yeah d tackle defensive tackle how'd you
know
just the body type so brandon got the
body of like a defensive end or outside
linebacker
yeah is that where you were uh well same
on the
i was on the offensive end of it so i
was like so that's that's the air on
hernandez
yeah yeah yeah without the murdering
yeah whatever yeah
and the gay stuff you'd be a fullback
what's that that's what i told him yeah
you're a fool will you pull up the
definition of fullback sure the fullback
is the
shortest league short yards short yards
i lead the way you do a lot of blocking
yeah i just do blocking mike i asked
that
jim brown no he's a straight up running
back oh he was there's a fullback still
like they stopped using fullbacks these
days but
there's a fullback for the baltimore
ravens who is thick
he's 300 pounds and that boy can move oh
really you never seen him no
oh my god because it's it's real so now
it's such a passing game
yeah but raven said [ __ ] that man we're
gonna roll with lamar jackson and we got
this 300 pound fullback who can move
and they got mark ingram right yeah yeah
yeah that's and that's why the running
game is so powerful this dude's
dead so fullback bring bring up that
fullback for
uh baltimore ravens fullback yeah yeah
yeah you're right i don't even know that
you had some uh juicy running backs like
uh
patrick yes that's him ricard he's 363
311. holy [ __ ] you want to tackle that
bro you should see him [ __ ] move
people out the way it's insane
you know who i'm at didn't make it bro
bo scarborough
oh i know i don't know he was a freak
athlete beast
he blew up a video you have a video dude
without doing his thing are you
do you still follow football college
only only college who's your team
bam bama yeah how are you gonna be a
bama fan from georgia because that's
where i was going to play football
oh you're going to go to bama yeah and
then what happened just messing up
grades no behavior yeah oh yeah you told
me yeah you said a lot of it was your
behavior yeah like
where's the guy at that's him pancaking
that dude 42 in the back there
oh [ __ ] 311 can move boom
oh my gosh all right
players to watch because no one really
[ __ ] the fullback anymore
yeah all thick but what was that boy's
name uh refrigerator perry
yeah he played play fullback uh
this dude's like that's like his
full-time gig though oh like
in the nfl that no one really [ __ ] the
fullbacks so when some college does but
so when you start football you just went
hardworking your dream was to make to
the nfl that was my thing i was going to
the nfl yeah
and then uh went to school in college in
georgia for like one year and i was just
getting a lot of trouble bro like i like
fighting and [ __ ]
bro i was so what was that college you
said you went to
uh making state and gmc yeah gmc
where is that it's in georgia oh yeah
when you're giving us a ride
in that tesla it's a military company i
was like where'd you guys at
supplements right gmc georgia military
college georgia military college tried
to get it right
uh but dog like uh the thing that made
me know i had to move to la
uh a guy who i was hanging tough with
his name is uh cedric denard
and this chick actually like saved me
from going to prison
so um he called me he was like hey i
need you to
give me a ride a little later and i said
all right i got you bro
and uh when i was supposed to go give
him a ride
uh my girlfriend at the time uh was like
no you haven't been over here in a while
get your ass over here
are we done so i went to go see her
and i text cedric i was like hey bro my
bad i can't give you a ride man i never
got a text message back
yeah like damn he mad at me because i
didn't give him a ride so me and her
chilling in her bed
it's like the 11 o'clock news come on
cedric dinard's face
is on the 11 o'clock news bro he the
right i was giving him was to go sell a
cell phone but he had
he was trying to rob the guy for the
money and still keep the cell phone so
in georgia
if you're uh what is it called the
getaway driver the getaway driver or a
round or the admission of a group
guilty by social media gives you by
association so i'm pretty sure
knowing me i would have got out of the
car and walked with him to sell the
phone because i would have been oh
that's your guy yeah make sure he'll rob
you and then like that and he was going
to rob the guy
so i told uh the girl ronda was her name
i said anytime anywhere you can get
anything from me
because we sat there watching shout out
to ronda we sat there and watched it on
the news man
like [ __ ] robbery so then when did you
come out to l.a shortly after that like
three months later
you know yeah you get the l.a yeah my
cousin actually was a rapper
and uh like a legit rapper like
soundcloud getting bigger
yeah and he had a tour in la and
basically he was like
because i was trying to find a way to
get out here i didn't know anybody
didn't know i had family out here at the
time
and uh i was like all right man like he
was like
we're going to la in four weeks you got
four weeks to get your [ __ ] together i
was like i
bet scared as hell i'm like 19. yeah
yeah about to be 20.
uh first time i'll be this far away from
my family
and uh came out here and made it work
man and then how did you get the gig at
the commie store
um so my youngest daughter's mom
in 2019 uh i was
about to like just you know like hang it
up during comedy because i had my second
kid on the way
and i was just about to like go back to
college and she was like i'll support
you this year
but you have to go out to the comedy
store at least twice a week
because i i sucked at like uh networking
yeah so she was like you're gonna go on
mondays and you're going to find another
day to go to the comedy so you're going
to stay there all day
that's dope yeah so um every monday
she would make me go to the comedy store
and there's this one monday
i did not want to go to the comedy store
because like i have been signing up for
the bucket for like
what a potluck yeah like three months
one getting pulled
i'm just like man i'm tired of this [ __ ]
like you know what i'm saying yeah
and the monday i didn't want to go i
told her i would be at the house and
she's like if you're at the house when i
get home from work
pack your bags
this is my young my youngest daughter's
mom the the
jamaican the jamaican hell yeah yeah if
you're home when i get home
pack your bag i'm taking my ass to come
right
back i got
adam has seen me before it but he's
never offered me a family a friend spot
he was like
hey david what are you doing in like two
weeks
it did i did uh family and friends again
and uh quincy
was telling me at that time i think
quincy weekly quincy weekend yeah
funk child got fired you should uh try
to get the position i was like well put
it in adam's ear
and then adam saw me like david you want
to be a door guy
yeah i was like yeah cause there
you know i'm like yeah think about the
door guy alumni man
yeah yeah rogan yeah alumni
there's [ __ ] mark marin tony stair his
clue
jesus trejo yeah jim carrey man poston
bobby lee bobby lee it's the navy seals
of comedy
yeah so uh he put me on facebook see
that's exactly what it is
the navy seals the comedy he promote uh
family and friends
uh a lot of the comedians at the comedy
store out of jealousy
probably were like man that's just well
one is particular he's like that's a
stupid ass move bro you going backwards
i'm like
ooh meanwhile do you know how like how
the game works dog
he was like you going backwards i'm like
he's like you already
he's like you already got such-and-such
followers and you got this on youtube
like why would you want to work here
and then when i got there i saw why he
didn't want me to work there you know
what i'm saying because you
you started getting a lot of getting a
lot of you know also every headliner
comes through there
they see you but also you really
talented so it's like
i mean it was adamant i don't want to be
there if you're not yeah he would
it's it's hard but at the comments when
i got to the comedy store bro like i
started
like uh you know like you could tell
guys who've been in late
forever that shouldn't still be there
and they're like when i first started
uh you couldn't even get a spot for the
first six months and i'm like well
stuff changes
my first thought ever was in the bedroom
while i was doing laundry mats on here i
don't know what to tell you dog that
what do you want me to do they offered
me the spot i [ __ ] went and did it
exactly
so like um i would uh like they give me
a lot of the opening spots and a lot of
people just you know
like you know you might not like me at
first but then when you get to know me
it's like
i'll be doing that i'll be chilling yeah
yeah yeah yeah
so it's like ain't really nothing to
hate so you know you become friends with
those guys like hey man you want to come
open the main room like yeah i'll come
up in the main room and then when i work
in the belly room i would kind of like i
wouldn't say bully but i persuade them
to put you on to put me on because i had
to go through the safety announcements
so i'm like hey
let's start the show 10 minutes earlier
i'll do
you know five six minutes and then i'll
get a safety announcement they're like i
like that
yeah that's great yeah yeah good for you
man that's hustle dog
but like networking was already in you
you just said no and someone just had to
push you
just you know got real bad social
anxiety man i know you told me
uh i take cbd for it now so as well that
helps with anxiety for sure so
it helps you do that vaping yeah i do my
vape all the time my baby mama called
him my pacifier
yeah but he hit it like 70 times in the
green room i was like
okay man he goes i got social anxiety
dogs
there was a lot of people in that green
room yeah especially if i don't know him
you know what i'm saying like my first
time you know
yeah it's always weird right because
when we first met
we first met we first met at the comedy
store
uh you were i have a great memory you
were on
yeah yeah you were on some show in the
belly room it was like a a weekday
i wasn't working but i was working at
the comment show at the time
and i how i because i don't really know
how to like start a conversation i was
like hey bro we got the same manager
the friendliest guys and i was going
someone goes hey man they started my own
where they want me
yeah no yeah yeah you are a friendly
dude yeah i remember that
but you're a friendly dude i am very
friendly yeah it's like
you have anxiety today even though you
know obviously you're respecting the
space
yeah dude has it gotten better i took a
cbd before i came so now i take cbd when
i wake up and it normally helps
how strong that cbd have you used the
drops yeah i used to drop some time i do
um like a 10 milligram in the morning
and like
um the gummies or something yeah you'll
be paying for it
yeah i got you all right yeah i got it
yeah come on
i knew i saw what you were yeah he's
hooked me up yeah
it gets you and he's got the you got
them drops yeah and like when i fly by
myself i got to take cbd
oh really if i fly with a chick or a
friend and i'm able to talk like
like but if you're by yourself like you
know about myself like my thoughts get
to me you know what i'm saying
for sure yeah i don't have nobody like
yeah i have to take it at night because
i can't shut off
like my mind like when i get on the
plane i just accept
death you know what i'm saying yeah
cause you don't if that makes sense it's
just like all right i could die
let me just accept that i feel like
everyone has that agreement
like this is probably wild as [ __ ] yeah
look man
i've seen that [ __ ] yeah i'm drunk right
now
yeah i always look in the cockpit i'm
like well all right here we go
i guess i'm gonna trust this dude like
we're so trusting
it's like when you go on a [ __ ] ride
at six flags i guess they service this
[ __ ] thing yeah good i'll hang upside
down and go
90 000 miles an hour a lot of my anxiety
is not being in control
yes oh okay there it is so because it's
like bro like i
i have a hard time like if we're on a
road trip sleeping in the car with
somebody driving
i'd be tired as hell and stay up late
yeah oh for real yeah
because i'm not in control you know what
i'm saying like you don't [ __ ] keep
doing this
uh christian we have uh rate my state
yeah hey man maybe you got kids maybe
out of animals and dinner time can be
chaotic but not with freshly yep it's
easy the chefs take care of your meals a
few nights a week and take the pressure
off you man
don't be sweating anymore freshly offers
chef made nutrient packed delicious
meals
delivered fresh to your door no cooking
required that's right
grocery shopping cooking it's a pain not
anymore right now you want to wear a
mask roll around the store
don't be that person ordering is easy
visit freshly.com
choose from over 30 delicious recipes
all right
and also fresh you can fit your
lifestyle they have variety plans
whether you're thick
skinny whatever you're looking for we
got you covered man your meals are
always delivered fresh never frozen
and are ready to heat and enjoy in just
three minutes with new meals added each
week
freshly brings the convenience of chef
made nutritious design classics right to
your kitchen right now
freshly is offering the fighter and the
kids listeners 40 bucks off your first
two orders
when you go to freshly.com fighter stop
stressing out dinner
let us take it man go to freshly.com
fighter for 40
40 off your first two
orders that's freshly.com fighter for 40
off your first two orders this episode
is also brought to you by bluetooth my
boys yo my boy blue bluetooth is making
waves bringing more confidence to the
sack
that's right bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra cialis but
in chewable form all right at a fraction
of the cost
blue chew is a tablet that combats all
forms of ed
helps you gain a little extra boost in
the sac bluetooth is an online
prescription service
so no visits to the doctor no
conversations no way in line the
pharmacy skip all that ships
right to your door little discreet
package all right process simple sign up
at bluetooth.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days again it's all done
online all right so if you could benefit
from extra comments when it's time to
perform with your lady oyomens
visit bluechew.com for more details
important safety information
i got a deal for you boys
try bluetooth free when you use the
promo code fighter at checkout
just pay five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com bluelightcolorbluechu.com
promo code fighter
receive your first month free and i
thank bluechu for being part of the
fighting the kids
this episode of firing the kids with
david lucas and chappelle lace out laces
is brought to you by anna it's their
semi-annual
sale popping right now alpha brain
shroom tech
protein powder workout gear everything
you need to keep your thick ass in shape
anna got you covered go to onit.com
fighter 10 off their entire damn site
the best supplements on planet earth is
brought to you by
on it and they have one hell of a sale
for you right now it's a semi
annual yearly sale is going on right now
it's their biggest sale of the year
go check them out on it.com slash
fighter 10 off anything
good luck oh we do yeah so we got a
segment your emmy you're born for this
segment we got to see
yeah he's born we got a segment on here
where people send in because we always
say where
la 6's we gave everyone an la score you
know well now we got to give
david an la score i'm in la 12 this
[Laughter]
month
she's 35 uh was that washington
richfield washington i'm titty's 22
though
[Laughter]
black rifle coffee shirt on too real for
washington
uh for for washington oh she looks like
the only republican in washington
firing guns and [ __ ] damn she's smoking
so here's the thing that gets me
uh like i would need to know were those
kids born in wedlock
yeah that's fair yeah why'd that end
huh we'll add that in next time yeah
yeah yeah
how old were you when you had your first
kid everything oh that's just
kidding oh
my son got his first haircut yesterday i
saw that oh boy she got
yeah she know how to ride a horse oh
yeah look at the way she's sitting on
that damn thing
she's bad regardless she's straight
i would give her an la 9. i was i was
good
yeah i gave her a nine she's a west
coast or washington ten
yeah ellie and i know la nina was yeah
washington too
you were gonna the white girls at all
david um
because it killed tournament the white
girls but they got to approach me i
don't approach them
this day is smart
you gotta go talk to me would you give
her chin
um jim's a bit of a hater he's like i'm
not hating him
he's not going to see a bad [ __ ] on
instagram but her elbows are pointy
get when i see plastic surgery it looks
kind of fake for some reason that turns
me off the only thing that's fake on her
no no that's not not her she's actually
like a 7.58
so what's a 10 for you like who would
you call it
i know right no right he likes girls
that are built like that [ __ ]
camera
breakable that girl we saw yesterday on
um
with ben affleck she's probably the
closest to a 10 that i've seen in a
while she's had all the work done chin
yeah no she's just just her lips
pull her up her entire girl
and plus there's a lot of i think she's
better than that instagram chick
yeah she's definitely i give her a la
six bro oh
six oh tough cookie six you've heard
only 35 three kids
la six yeah yeah that's a little school
i can't tell her to come over whenever
see look at you and your drama
she has too much face mask just too much
come on chin are you tripping you can't
talk about plastic surgery and then
reference that
i gotta say something i like him all
natural like kylie jenner
you might have to get him you might have
to give him some lasik surgery
i agree i think she's at la9 yeah and
then washington like 12.
yeah solid the best looking thing in
washington and watching the city
whoever she wants yeah what do you give
a christian
ten washington 10 la 9. she's five four
same height as you
oh hey look hi doug true hey
sure she looks like she needs a beast
huh she looks like she needs an owl
yeah i would be a guy oh yeah you're
shooting guns and archery and all that
yeah woodwork black rifle woodworking
yeah come on
she look like she she got a dude who's
like shop size so
yeah oh yeah one game she's probably
gonna know how to fight too yeah she
looks like first team
she looks like first team all maggots
right
she's one of the few that voted red in
washington
what else you got jen one time
the numbers got six nine seven nine
nine yeah david said six four nines
though
it's a solid [ __ ] score
it's got all quiet mother of four
though would work for another woodworker
part of the thick boy
girl club hmm
is there any oh different pick
she's got the old school gages family
look at her boyfriend i beat his ass and
take her
what state is she from chin she doesn't
say yeah it doesn't say
uh based off those bushes i could say
that's my hometown it could be colorado
that could be idaho or some [ __ ] uh huh
yeah i wish we knew what state she was
from
yeah that she looks bad there mm-hmm
five feet too
i'd get rid of it you're right you're
looking at her liking yeah i give her
you know what that's a good [ __ ]
score chris that's fair hey i give her
something give it up
for two she got a dude so i could just
be a part-time dude
like i got a lot of factors in so yeah
he can't he can't beat me up
she's with him for financial stability i
see the gray in the side of his hair
i'll be analyzing everything i know
right
she's the wild one though how's that
yeah absolutely titty
[ __ ] tat i think you've gotten the
chest gages in the ear
you're savage oh she has gages oh yeah
bro she has girls night three times a
week
she can't wait for half an hour [ __ ]
babysitting
and leave her at her duties with the
kids
yeah she yeah i get ready i give her an
eight solid eight two
solid couldn't be convinced into nine
damn kind of killed it with the ladies
today
who picked these christian yeah just
what
this one's funny oh oh gosh yeah
wait someone do huh
do this one or what yeah st louis
missouri
yeah yeah okay bro
hey bro chill just read the read the
[ __ ]
i know recently from missouri st
missouri
511 150 nurse for 26 years amster muay
thai champion out of st
louis yeah damn she said okay
okay why is this one in there oh she's
with that same guy
that's her husband oh she needed her
husband
yeah remember we thought it was a girl
his name's shannon
like saint louis like an older stevie
blue yeah yeah that's older
stevie blue yeah i remember
i think he's just gonna have a mohawk
like that with his hair
on the sides dipping out uh
go back to her chain scroll through her
pics again first one they use a titties
as a punching bag
i'll let david take the lead i mean
i can't worry yeah it's like kathy
gifford transitioning
i give her a four
that's real though yeah it's tough what
do you give her missouri though well
that body though
i'll give her a seven what
what is that what's that bad seven's
good that was good i'm a david i think
it's a
little high i'd say five that body
though she's 47
yeah and 45 she kicked you right in the
face with it
i'm 34 look at my body facts
you see what i'm saying i can't give her
a four
chris uh what do you give her chin why
me man
we're all in it hey there man yeah what
are you talking about i don't want to
actually say it but it's lower than
anyone else has given her i think oh you
won't even give her a four
this just isn't chin style 3.8
okay i'll give her a four dude no you
don't do don't feel pressure no no i
mean
for some reason keep your three points
this girl would peg you dog she would
destroy it yeah
she she's a nurse yeah like i know
she'll take that she's like yeah she
takes care of herself
she looks like how much
uh lori i give you seven all the way
honey i'm gonna give her a six
okay look at seven six four christian
four four cat i give her a sex
it's so for her age with her body to be
able to keep that's what i'm saying and
a nurse
exactly i could never drop her to her
it's like you were seven also she would
kick all of our asses
yeah except for brendan's stuff oh no
man you think you can take her they
don't make bulletproof bodies
ain't nobody beating up on me no more
[Laughter]
it kind of sucks being honest about this
right but i mean that's they know what
we're gonna
we're gonna be honest about it so i
apologize
laurie don't apologize stick with it
i mean i mean you can't just be giving
tens out yeah i know i mean obviously
people know what you're
what what the segment is the problem is
the first one was a bona fide
smoke show and then you bring in this
[ __ ] you know
it's also a comedy podcast some people
do calm down yeah
yeah they know what they're saying we're
just having fun oh damn baby blues
6'4 195 that means this boy shredded
california four
i don't think so dog michigan michigan
seven eight
oh he's a little model yeah he must be a
model
on the game spectrum
that structure the bone struck the
crimson chin yeah yeah
[Laughter]
i would give him a californian
those pictures that one with him in a
suit that's kind of he looks yeah but
that's how you get catfish he looks like
a floyd
yeah yeah it looks like a basic [ __ ]
right there
six four one ninety five that means if
he learns how to smile
he'll he's awkward i don't know why he
sent that one and that's what he looks
like a bit
does he look six foot forty for some
reason doesn't seem like he's probably
he probably is
six four one ninety five special right
there
i think that's when he was real that
looks like prom
yeah well i don't know why he said the
problem if he grows some facial hair to
cover up that chin he'll be a tear
definitely
that's fair yeah like he when he gets a
beer will he get his beard game bro all
right then i'll give him a
eight human eight
la eight i'm gonna give him la nine well
he's a he's a west hollywood nine for
sure
no he was hollywood ten yeah twenty oh
my
god yeah twenty
six four 195 the blue eyes yeah yeah
you're right
he's 20. that boy is fresh me there yeah
yeah right
boys
yeah and if that's how you are man
that's that's cool oh nice
man we support you yeah la-8 for me bro
yeah dude
if if that is your thing you come to l.a
you can all the dick you can handle i'll
tell you that you could drive that
maybach truck in my apartment
at least right shotgun i think this man
is a solid nine because he would
also be a hot ass girl if you put a wig
on yeah you're right
tuck that scrotum back that boy
hey tuck the
[Laughter]
we got another one last one tampa
canada what they just making [ __ ] up
yeah
time between the two no tampa canada is
their chin that can't be real
62 200 pounds firefighter emt amateur
fighter
mexican spanish caramel poppy hazel eyes
it is cinco de mayo so be cool man yeah
what else you got
he has more chin yeah yeah i'm just
checking out tampa campus is that you're
my favorite chin
i don't see tampa canada by the way yeah
he lives in canada he lives in tampa but
he's from canada
that's what's going on yeah so we got to
give him a 10 oh
okay okay did that fireman [ __ ] yeah
calendar spreadsheet it wasn't late in
my book
oh you give him a tag yeah he would kill
it out here yeah he would kill it out
here
he would take all the black girls bro
yeah them eyes
ronnie yeah yeah he'd kill it i'm gonna
give him
i'll give him an eight oh bro he yeah he
would kill him are you an eight
i wouldn't leave them around my chick no
not that that guy
those other the pigs are tough they're
so different that one
he said that guy i wouldn't i wouldn't
[Laughter]
yeah yes the em emt
pic that gets me he's oh that he's from
tampa florida not
canada how do i play canada you put
canada no i just i forwarded the email
oh word oh god again okay tampa florida
tampa florida nine i'd give him an la7
but i also wouldn't if i was eating at
javier's with my girl i went to the
bathroom i came back he was sitting
there i'd be nervous oh be nervous
this guy right that guy right there that
guy right there he wears that
he makes me nervous yeah me too makes me
nervous he's a good-looking waiter at
the restaurant
yeah yeah and honestly might have to
take the l you know
yeah maybe
i'll give him a seven i'll give him
later yeah he'd kill it out here
is that it that's it all right what you
got for current events jay
let's see
not letting trump on facebook he's doing
his own [ __ ] right
he's got his own
what it is it's like a way for him to
bypass all of it so he can still be on
there it's weird right kind of like this
i kind of i guess kind of like what alex
jones is doing oh
god he got it okay so
um on monday we were talking about will
smith gaining weight and
mark wahlberg actually posted this
before and after photo
he is currently on the route to gain 30
pounds for a roll i guess he's 20 pounds
up
and this is what he looks like oh god
damn
so that's what he was three weeks ago
and then now he looks like that yeah
how do you do that in three weeks three
weeks he said that he was
under such a restrictive diet for so
long trying to stay fit that
now he's just eating whatever the [ __ ]
he wants he's a beast yeah that boy
would be working out
hard too yeah yeah buddies that work
algorithm like monsters
he does he's doing his schedule is
insane does he own those f45s
yeah he's part of it yeah part of it
yeah that's what i thought one boy who's
australian his son goes to school with
my son he he actually owns him but mark
wahlberg's a
partner in it got it okay okay he's the
one working out with me dude he's an
animal
dude him and four brothers which is
one of my favorite people dude lone
survivor
fire come on patriots day is uh the
boston bombing movie
oh god he plays like uh that one's
really that's a really good one oh he
goes into that remember when they tried
to cancel him for something he did when
he was 18
when he beat up that asian dude he
sucker punched an asian dude he beat him
half blind with a stick and
but then they went to the asian dude in
boston he's like man i'm good get out of
here
and it just shut everybody down like oh
[ __ ] yeah it was one of those weird
situations i think it was
four patriots day or a movie that he did
uh a few years back where he wanted to
become an honorary cop because he was
doing the process of research for a film
and they said that he couldn't because
of that felony
and they went back and tried to do an
interview with the vietnamese guy that
he beat in the vietnamese guys like he
was a young kid who didn't know any
better he grew up like
oh when he got all juicy oh with the
rocks
when the rock was like give me every
steroid you have yep and that mark was
like i'll have the same
people who anthony all of them did
steroids
oh he was yeah yeah you know that's a
true story yep yeah
you've seen painting games painting
games pockets it's a pretty dope
you've never seen the rock more juicy
it's the crazy that's when the rock
light got hurt
what's up he was bigger than hercules
dude yeah like different like
he's like lean he's just massive in this
yeah i think that was like the first
time
you saw him that big damn yeah look at
him
what's that one rock movie i i love it a
lot it's the one where he's got the
little daughter
he's a football player um
movie see gameplay got juicy too for
that damn that's a great [ __ ] movie
oh macky is huge where's mackey yet
right here
oh wow look anthony maggie papadop
papadopoulos [ __ ] the free world man
look at the rock i know crazy bro jesus
that nuts
yeah mark mark wahlberg so what's the
name of this movie painting painting
the wildest story it's all over it's all
over yeah
wildest story tonight but yeah mark
wahlberg's schedule is crazy right like
he wakes up at like 3 30 or something
yeah
he like works out for two hours and then
he has breakfast he prays
he does a bunch of work he takes like a
midday nap
his schedule is insane is i think from
like two in the morning to
7 p.m and then the rest of the time he's
sleeping
that's awesome go sleep at seven yeah
i should with kids i've been in bed by
nine but sometimes when i got back wake
up at five yeah
we got about nine yeah yeah it's a dude
two kids on your own
you know b's yeah do you live by
yourself no i got a roommate
oh okay what else you got you all right
so this tell me if the story reminds you
of anybody you know
um there was a man in boston
massachusetts who owned a pizza shop
who was down on his luck during covid
uh signed up for a ppp loan got it he
then sold
his pizzeria moved to vermont bought a
farm then bought a bunch of alpacas
started
to have in apaca farm and the government
found out that he
was doing wire fraud and money
laundering and now he is currently
arrested
is there money in alpaca farms i don't
think i think this is like purely
something that he
wanted for himself like a personal thing
god damn he's looking at
uh if he's found guilty they both could
get 40 years in prison finds up
50 grand i'll be locking up a lot of
people yes especially those fake ppp
loans mm-hmm
they don't [ __ ] around no they don't
[ __ ] what exactly is
hit because like everything went down
okay so like even
for us it's like you know the first
thing that would go when there's a
like uh pandemic stuff like that is
advertising
which is what how we survive right so if
that gets cut in half or even less than
that
then the bank be like hey usually make
this which we realize you can't get so
we'll give you a loan to make up for it
so you can still pay your employees
so that's what he did took that money
and then when he probably
built up how much he spent in a month
because they'll look at everything and
they probably gave mono a couple hundred
thousand for his pizza i believe it was
six
hundred and sixty thousand dollars what
they gave him which is a ton a ton
and then he went about alpaca
what else you got jen okay so we were
talking about this
uh the other show now that bill and
melinda gates are officially filing for
diver
but i'm deleting tinder a bunch of fake
dating apps with both of their pictures
on it
bruh how hilarious they're doing ah look
at that i can give you an exclusive
third dose
i saw the funniest meme where it said uh
you know so many people are going after
rogan for his vaccination [ __ ]
yeah and it you know it was like oh
since when did joe rogan become a doctor
the next headline was all this advice
from bill gates as far as vaccines go
yeah ain't a [ __ ] doctor either
dumbass but then they would post
all his [ __ ] like he was like yeah
[ __ ] fouchy yeah
that's so true that's so [ __ ] true
but yeah the memes around this is so
funny there was a video going viral of
this older
white woman on a yacht throwing a bunch
of money and there's like a yeah a bunch
of like young black and dancing
like showing her a good time dude
i wonder if bill's just like yeah i'm
trying to get a bad [ __ ] man
mate do you think he can get a bad [ __ ]
yes he's actually
yeah yeah you're right you're right
you're right you're right you're right
you're right what
you're right you're [ __ ] you're right
i think he's second richest man on a
third
he goes elon jeff bezos then bill yeah
that yeah he's an la-10
wasn't the uh richest man on earth like
the longest time
yeah for the longest and he also has
like he lives in a cave
in [ __ ] seattle like he lives like
his house is like a mountain he's like
dr
evil there's like underneath tunnels and
[ __ ] it's this crazy crib
you see uh santino dm bill gates
yeah he dm bill gates he's like hey uh
you went to redhead so i can send it to
him i thought it was [ __ ]
who's oh the lvm lvmh uh people
lvmh it was i think that's the louis
vuitton and people who own it
damn enough isn't it am i right
lvmh don't like louis vuitton and a lot
of other exclusive stuff
yeah people don't realize like all those
like upper echelon like fashion browns
are all underwater yeah you're right
yeah oh [ __ ] oh they're almost done yeah
hmm goddamn [ __ ] yeah they're all like
see that see they on louis vuitton
yep all that
that's crazy yeah i wonder if bill gates
just didn't get a bad
instagram thought he would maybe be
singing
he's doing weird i probably get 10 of
them yeah that's what i do if i see him
i i feel like he already has one though
in it
if i was if i'm here absolutely bro
because he got the money
well he raised 57 yeah 65. 65.
wait hold on
like three years i'm 65. yeah i i go two
years in the paint hard as [ __ ] and then
i find a wifey
jeff made a 57 with that sniper eye and
then
and then he got up
[Laughter]
and then he started uh not when he was
married they're like separate start
dating that
was she like a not a weather girl but
like a news reporter yeah yeah
and then she also has a [ __ ] guy didn't
his wife marry like a basic
uh science teacher yeah bro was that
with me
that could have been dog got on to look
at her oh you were oh they both got it
both
[ __ ] they say i die
he's like damn girl i see that eye one
right what are you doing here that's how
they linked up they're like damn
you got a [ __ ] up body too right i was
looking across the way
i got my good eye on you look at him
yeah he he definitely upgraded yeah
yeah she's a baddie and then her brother
tried blackmailing
him because he was sending her dick pics
i mean you know jeff bezos
[ __ ] sent a few dick pics so he was
sent her dick pics and her brother got a
hold of him and that was trying to
blackmail jeff bezos
how did her brother what was he like he
was like if you don't give me money i'll
put these up jeffy is like do it [ __ ]
are you scared of you put them out there
but i sent them an amazon pack you open
up said do it right
hilarious what else you got jen all
right so
uh we had this video yesterday and chris
christian was right
the girl that was a being a douchebag to
the cop was
her voice sounds white your voice does
sound white that's that's why i was like
second guessing
oh [ __ ] maybe they're right maybe i just
didn't see it but then like i looked
back and i saw
the hand of it yeah all right that's a
good kind of you wanna see it real quick
we'll get and then she goes you'll never
be white using your cell phone while
you're driving that's it
yeah it doesn't make any sense oh racist
right here
because the one we saw the face was
blurred i don't know
and then her voice should never be white
so i figured there's another white
person
saying that yeah like nicole or
something like the whitest name
but we were all like oh that's
definitely white girl was like
she's black take it easy little maggots
where was this at like azusa or
something right west oh it was out here
west side oh damn that's just la
she's a dumb ass she's not white yeah i
don't know how people still do stupid
stuff
i can be a teacher talking all that she
was so she was a teacher yeah yeah she's
a professor
oh oh sh yeah pregnant fire yeah
yeah so irritating yeah all right uh
ochocinco is gonna be boxing on the
undercard for logan paul versus floyd
mayweather uh i don't want this
you know i love that this out because i
found out about this like two weeks ago
god damn it who's he fighting no
no word yet no oh most likely just
another athlete or a celebrity
he probably might do good does he need
money he probably spent all his money
i think it's just i think it's just
something for them to do i think i
literally think
a lot of these athletes are just bored
as [ __ ] and just something like a
uh passion like project chad chad uh
ocho single he'll be skateboarding he
made a ton of money yeah you go he goes
skateboarding he should fight kishon
johnson they like the same name oh
that'd be cool
yeah who's keyshawn johnson uh why
receive it for the uh
sc was the number one pick in the draft
i'd say michael vick
or steve smith oh steve smith would be
cool or who didn't chad have issues
with some cornerback when he's playing i
forget
i wonder who he's going to fight because
uh what what card is lamar odom and
aaron carter on not that card
[Laughter]
have you seen the videos of him it's a
nightmare yeah it's crazy
i pray to god he's not on that card who
aaron carter
i can't i gotta draw the line oh gosh oh
thank god
it's on it's on dog oh that's horrible
no it's there
like why is aaron carter fighting
obviously not up to no good
and then lamar odom why is he fighting
for money
clearly to buy math
it's the worst even that they're like no
one's saying that seriously no
it's a nightmare [ __ ] horrible
nightmare it's on dog nobody's i always
say this if you ever see me in a
celebrity boxing match
and easy on the celebrity but if you
ever see me in a celebrity boxing match
things ain't going well the podcast
ain't popping the merch ain't selling
i'm not selling any tickets on the road
man that [ __ ] is so depressing to me oh
all right we were just talking about
this dude shohei ohtani
and he i guess he did something that was
like
really hard to do oh you're talking
about the the korea
the chinese kid uh japanese japanese
yeah so i'll
play this for i guess a ground ball it's
hard to get to second base if you just
do a ground ball he got it done
so i'll just play real quick there's
some 1985.
another 002 from glass now
third baseman come up with us going to
second
he will slide in god damn hell yeah
safe there and they also hit a him a
home run here
and then he also pitches this is what's
[ __ ] he's like yeah he's a pitcher
yeah he's a pitcher he does both dude
that's what i'm saying that he's a beast
yeah
he's like a throwback japanese babe so
crazy yeah just doing both
[ __ ] yeah dude i know he's massive and
they got [ __ ] trout too
like [ __ ] up i'll buy his [ __ ] jersey
well he's chinese
japanese japanese i'll buy japanese
jersey not buying chinese
they'll be made in china probably but
yeah i mean these shoes are main
channels yeah
all of our shoes are made in china so
much so much of what we have is made but
in china come on nike
all right so there's another teacher
that uh had sexual relations with kids
oh is she bad what she looks like so i'm
gonna wait so they're 13 to 16
and she was a cafeteria worker so some
of the oh gosh
bruh even after even at 13 to 16 i
wasn't looking at the kevin no
most most people weren't at that time
not never but they're always really nice
they are yeah they always made those
square pizzas yeah they hook you
like i get the square pizza they give me
two of them
i'd wash it down with a strawberry milk
that [ __ ] was fire
but they're mostly like you look at them
as grandmas or ants that kind of yeah
so she would let them watch porn and
then give them alcohol and then she did
have sexual encounters with some of them
so this is her oh
38 years old by the way 38.
yeah that's the most shot out 38 year
old i beat my son ass
hell yeah bro i'm sure it was a good
time
you could do better if she was bad we'd
all be like oh good for the kids but
i just feel bad for them now teachers
but sometimes there's some baddies when
you look like
oh you know josh and randy ran a train
on [ __ ] teacher amy like let me see
amy some dime piece i'm like damn amy
what's wrong
anywhere else that's what's funny about
it like why them
because they were popular
dude can you imagine me in high school
you and your best friend run a train on
the english teacher
you can't wait to tell you
everybody's about to know oh dude
everybody knows everyone their mom
there weren't teachers in your high
school that like hooked up with
when they were of age there were no
teachers really there was like
three there was one teacher that legit
went through the entire football team
was she hot so bad oh wow that's cool
and then there was like another one i'm
not
obviously i'm not saying names but she
literally was going to
leave her husband for one of the kids
that like she was
this was a different teacher she's
mentally ill she didn't leave her
husband and kids for a 16 year old yeah
what was that that's where
someone got shot where uh it was a
student and a teacher
and i think the student went to their
the house and was it the husband that
shot them or something like that you
ever hear that
no no some guy's going to point it out
i know i know we had a he was like yo
he's the lacrosse uh
girls coach and he was like younger that
was the only rumor i heard he was
[ __ ] like all the lacrosse girls
and i was like yeah what'd you guys
think was happening right right he's way
too into women's but that's college
right
no that was high school that was a rich
school
well i'm not really lacrosse public
school aurora oh
colorado yeah uh nathan dunlap alumni
chuck e cheese shooting oh god oh that
was a horrific one yeah
how about i lived in the apartments
behind where chuck e cheese
we used to go choke cheese all the time
and then where his first victim he shot
in the face played dead ran into those
apartments that's where i lived
oh wow yeah we were young i remember
there's helicopters everywhere i was so
scared yeah
chuck e cheese cake is legit yeah it
used to be it means to be fun that
back and it's creepy as [ __ ] it was like
oh yeah it doesn't dance
nightmare it had that huge hose sticking
out from its helmet to its back or
something like that
oh um
turned into a salad and soup please yes
hey
oh no i just saw this i know stevie
knows this guy right yes
with him yeah here's what's inside about
george junk so you know the movie blow
you've seen blow yeah
uh so that's like that's johnny depp and
blow
so he uh was actually transitioning to a
uh
female what yeah yeah had a set of tits
really that's what i've that's what i
heard that people are the closest
situation i'm trying to spread rumors
especially on this
grapevine that's what i heard
yeah stevie woke up and found out this
morning it was uh liver failure
so so stiff you know stevie blue eyes is
i've seen him
yeah so he uh did some time and his
cellmate was george john
oh wow yeah they used to like write to
each other and [ __ ] and like pen pals
and [ __ ]
and stevie was gonna do a podcast with
him but yeah he was
not feeling well so he couldn't like
drive so he's like i'll zoom and i'm
like don't do a zoom all podcast
stevie okay uh yeah i mean he's bummed
out
yeah he unfortunately has a long history
of friends just kind of like
oh yeah i mean the guy lived there
yeah true yeah and if if that blow
movies any
you know is it most is there's truth to
it you know dude lived a [ __ ] life
maybe right made some horrible decisions
but right hopefully his daughter talked
to him before that movie was sad when he
when he was going to prison for a long
time and called his that
ending i cried so yeah and he died
tricked me out he was so sad
so sad it's so sad never seen it oh it's
a good movie
really good really good movie definitely
watch it all right
all right um i don't know how legit this
is but this bar still reposting it so
this is like the worst gender reveal
ever and i can't play the music so i'll
just play this for you real quick
he has to ride in the face of some [ __ ]
jesus christ he just keeps missing and
missing come on big boy
is that dj khaled i mean he also
he throws it himself too i mean come on
youtube like that you can't even hit it
there how can he not hit it
that was it so then we did he never hit
the [ __ ]
there's no update today you ever seen
the people that do that and then they
like die or some [ __ ]
like there's one with fireworks they
started a virus for sure
there's one dude who did it and like
they all died yeah
one of the fires in california was like
one that yeah this wildfire
started oh the one last year some
[ __ ] idiot not too long ago used a
pirate cannon
to [ __ ] yeah and he got killed i was
like that's what you get
for real just be cool man yeah did you
do anything for
football like some easy safe [ __ ] yeah
did you did you do anything
i got a [ __ ] cupcake my
brother-in-law bought it and then we cut
in the middle and the icing was gonna be
blue or pink oh that's good
yeah i'm trying to [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
yeah
yeah forget all that oh that's all hey
show that video which one oh
yeah chappelle in the wild bro the one
that everyone keeps tagging me
there's a video of you watch you look at
this dude i wonder if
there it is
it's funny because i literally shoot
like that
the funniest comment [ __ ] got a beer
belly
like
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
damn that [ __ ] is hilarious that's it
hell yeah where are you gonna be on tour
dog yeah i think coming up dates
uh what i'm in vegas on next week that's
stratosphere
and then right out here i don't know the
way he announced him
we're trying to turn things around here
we're the straps
but then after that you're in houston
with us
baby 22nd right uh yeah 20th 2017.
that's right let's get it houston improv
and then i'm in uh
[ __ ] when you guys listen to this uh
kentucky lexington kentucky this week
thursday friday saturday
two one show thursday two shows friday
two shows saturday lexington kentucky
uh what was it coming off broadway in
kentucky
then houston texas this crew you see
here right now will be at the houston
improv may 20th through 22nd
it's gonna be a beast of a show then
oklahoma city uh brickstown comedy club
june 10th through the 12th tickets at
fadkz.com
chappelle coming to philly i'll see you
this weekend may 7th through the 8th
at uh helium comedy club and then may
13-15 good night's
comedy club in raleigh north carolina
chappelle ac dot com for tickets boom
you've been talking to the boys at uh
suplex yeah we've been talking back and
forth with them
the homies bro they're going they're
going yeah they're going to show me
around if they're excited
if you give you a pair of shoes for me
don't be mailing them back now
talk about shoes bro i haven't been home
in three weeks just got home
yesterday to come to the pot bro
somebody stole like 1200
worth of stuff damn i was saying your
apartment board some [ __ ] yeah but it's
been sitting there for like two three
weeks you know what i'm saying
that's also what you get yeah where's
your roommate at they were out of town
damn right there's nothing they don't
get robbed and have you ever been robbed
and there's literally you tell stockton
like that's yeah they didn't
know that they died they're like
i'm just like oh that got delivered to
the door it got delivered so
all the packages that were supposed to
all the people that were not lazy and
delivered to my actual door
those packages were there but they left
outside these idiots left them in the
lobby
i remember as a kid my mom steal
packages
yeah she used to steal this neighbor her
neighbor played for the broncos the big
ass black dude left tackle
she's like hey i got you some socks i
was like oh dope mom because she's like
nike
i opened these [ __ ] up they were like
i just knew they were stolen but i never
say anything like thanks
can't wait to wear them shout out to mom
all right dude we love you man yeah